طائره ليونيل ميسي تصل الى ميامي وتقديمه
للجماهير يوم الاحد المقبل
هاري ماغواير يستعرض مهاراته في لعبه
الجولف
صفقه برشلونه الجديده تصف رونالدو بالافضل
[موسيقى]
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من العربيه
الرياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
وصل النجم الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي الى
ولايه فلوريدا الامريكيه تمهيدا لانضمامه
الى نادي انتر ميامي وظهر في مقطع فيديو
مسرب اثناء مغادرته لطائره الخاصه رفقه
عائلته تقارير اعلاميه اسبانيه اشارت الى
ان ميسي سيقدم للجماهير يوم الاحد المقبل
على ملعب لوكر الواقع خارج مدينه ميامي
وبالضبط في فورت لود
انتهت مشكله مدربي ريال مدريد كارلو
انشيلوتي مع القضاء الاسباني بعد التوصل
الى التسويات مما يتعلق بسداد ضرائب عام
2015 حيث اسقطت عنه بسبب تواجده في
بريطانيا في ذلك الوقت كما اثبتت في
التحقيقات ان المدربه بالفعل دفعت جميع
المستحقات الضريبيه عليه منذ عام 2014
وكانت المحكمه قد اذنت انشيلوتي في وقت
سابق بتهرب الضريبي وتغريبه مليون ونصف
مليون يورو
اعتادت جميع الكره القدم على السخريه من
قائد مانشستر يونايتد هاري ماغواير خاصه
في الموسم الماضي ماغواير منح جماهير كره
القدم فرصه جديده للسخريه منه بعدما نشر
فيديو له وهو يلعب الجولف المتابعون لم
يفوتوا الفرصه لاطلاق تعليقات مضحكه كما
ان اللاعب في حد ذاته اعترف بان اداءه كان
سيئا
يبدو ان المنطقه الحديثا الى برشلونه
بتروكي سيغضب بعض عشاق البلوغران مبكرا
حيث لم تمر عده ساعات على اعلان البارصا
التعاقد معه حتى تسللت بعض الجماهير الى
حسابه على تويتر وهناك غرد روكي عام 2021
بان كريستيانو هو الافضل ولا مجال
لمقارنته مع اي لاعب اخر ترى هل سيحدث
روكي هذه التغريده ام سيبقيها ويبقى على
رايه بان كريس هو الافضل في التاريخ